good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day
what a beautiful hump day we've got doo
doo doo
in the studio theodora
dora oh dora hey crunchy angel dora
precious lovely dora you know i love our
dora song i do
but do you know what it reminds me of
like that i have like a negative
association with like where we made it
up
oh we used to sing it when we were
leaving the old studio yeah and like i
hate that place since they evicted us so
like i just have like a
slight negative association with it oh
that's so funny because for me obviously
that's where the song was born but it's
just taken on a life of its own i i
forgot that that's how
every day when we would leave the studio
we would get him like put it ready sean
right and we should be like dude
we were on like the 30th floor literally
the whole time crunchy
angel cutest fur dora
smelly boy oh we other apology
you guys we owe theo an apology patrons
will know
why we recorded a patreon episode
yesterday all about
uh claudia's book we took all of your
questions that were left over from the
redheads episode or didn't make it for
various reasons we did a great episode
but towards the end of the episode it
started to smell up and
like literally smell and for me as a dog
mom i knew
immediately what that smell was i talk
about this all the time on the toes
probably more than i should but you know
dogs need to express their anal glands
i don't know what it really is but like
this juice comes out of their butt and
it is so
sickeningly disgustingly smelling it
smells like fish like it's so gross and
you if you've ever experienced like your
dog expressing your
his anal glands like you know the smell
yeah so i literally the episode was
winding down on my jacket do you smell
that
and i knew what it was and i was like we
gotta wrap this episode up and like we
basically talked about it for five
minutes shaming theo's anal glands which
wasn't cool of us
it wasn't cool of us and what turns out
to be even less cool of us is
then we packed up our things we left the
studio when we left the studio it
smelled so much worse
and the smell was coming from next door
i think they had ordered like fish for
lunch
and no that was not food no no i think
it was where else what else it sounded
like a septic explosion no
no because it was not a culinary school
it was like 12 30 the door was open oh
my god i think that they
ordered like a fish fiesta
no by the way in no way was you can't
to think that i misconstrued a smell of
fish with the smell of anal glands like
you just said they smell like fish i'm
sorry food it's not
food oh man that's sick i didn't think
that i thought that there was a pipe
burst
they had a fish fiesta no i totally
disagree
and so clearly it was not theo
responsibility
well that's the moral of the story and
we we embarrassed him then we're
embarrassing him again now
we're really sorry and we're really
sorry theo because it wasn't you we
literally
ran out of here we ran and it wasn't
even us
we should have stayed in here a hundred
percent so just wanted to clear that up
because
it was probably her fault for theo super
hurtful
um in the meantime head over to patreon
and listen to the episode because it's
really fabulous we cover the gamut on
things from the book
you know taking the conversation offline
some of the fanfare surrounding the book
and it's just a great so much fanfare
it's just a great episode of toastiness
between claude and i
and then also my book is available at
girl no job.com book i feel like i
really don't need to tell you guys that
because
like just the numbers keep coming in the
audiobook numbers i finally got and it's
like
we have so many listeners like you know
sometimes you feel like we're literally
talking into a void
yeah but they showed up and showed out
for the book launch
and i'm gonna stop i'm stop insulting
them with the promotion like they
already have it
for sure were they sickening audible
down they were sickening the audio
department
down wow we love to see it because we
love audio here
at the morning toast even though
sometimes ours is a little janky yeah
and even though we can't stop singing
yeah well you know what i gotta i did a
q and a uh like i always do and there's
always someone who's like please stop
singing
and i responded to it like no and
the amount of outpour like the
outpouring of love and support for the
singing like was enough to reinstill
my faith in our singing now of course
some episodes do we out do it yes
i wasn't sure what the girl was
referring to because i i have this
annoying habit of like
singing when i talk and it's like that
what she's talking about or
us singing like you know you're so
golden
[Music]
like is that what she's yeah she's
definitely talking about that specific
one because that wasn't so off pitch
yeah
let me try that again three two one
oh my god what i started singing you're
so golden yeah
so your pitch is like weird for the dues
sorry sorry
don't [ __ ] come for my pitch three
two two
one you're so golden
dude you're wrong dude
who's right together we're just bad
maybe in a few years from now we'll get
a little overheated already like the
show just started
into the chunky sweater today because i
feel like i've been wearing sweats
i'd be like no i'm like trying to wear
an outfit today like i'm wearing tights
i feel like i've been wearing sweats
in some way shape or form like you know
what's so funny today you have still
like was talking about my no i know
because the same thing is like i wore
this today because you've been wearing
so many sweats and then you show up in a
luke
in a turtleneck which has been your loop
and tights yeah
and chunky boots which has really been
your look i guess i've been inspired by
you and you've been inspired by me we'd
love to see it
inspiration is just reeking over here
you're just like being inspired by
wearing hoops every day yeah you know i
got so much
like positive feedback from my hoops and
i used to wear hoops all the time and
sometimes on the show i felt like it was
so
so much but now i'm feeling like like i
have a lot of you know
faith in my hoops and for those
wondering these are the ombre from the
new alison
ombre i haven't seen those those are
sickening and you know our friend margot
works for allison so i like we get some
free stuff but i actually purchased
these because like i wanted them so bad
i didn't want to wait to like you know
they weren't cool anymore until i could
finally get a free pair yeah for sure no
i love them
so i'm just like being poopy vibes very
hoopy vibes and i think that
being in this stage of quarantine or
whatever the [ __ ] we're in
like it's so important to like have
little things that just spice up
your everyday routine like when i was
wearing that prada necklace like i just
felt like
a whole new [ __ ] yeah and i can imagine
that's how you feel adding hoops to your
sweats no i
and hoops and sweats is a vibe for sure
but especially like a february 2021 six
degrees outside vibe
no i know and like it's six degrees
outside i'm sweating like a beast today
i know it is warm in here it is warm in
here
okay it's just theo being so sexy he
really actually now that i'm feeling it
it's like came over yeah
um we have a great show for you guys
today it's hump day deer toasters our
advice segment we actually have
so much to cover today because you
watched britney spears i watched the
britney spears doc uh
last night the real housewives of dallas
was on shouldn't take too long
should not take long at all because it
was literally one dinner party the whole
episode and
there's just fabulousness happening in
the world that i feel as though we need
to cover
yeah we do need to cover so i guess
without further ado it's time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
you know very sadly today's sponsor
remind me that tax season
is upon us you guys and it's never been
more important
to file your taxes no two people are
alike and no two tax returns are like
either
thankfully turbo tax live has
experienced tax experts who are ready to
listen to you
learn about your unique tax situation
and help you get the best
tax outcome maybe you got married this
year and have some questions about how
that affects your filing status
maybe you want an expert to walk you
through the process step by step so you
can make sure you didn't miss any
deductions on the new house you just
bought
or maybe you want to get the maybe you
want to hand the whole thing off from
start to finish
so you can focus on your burgeoning baby
photographer career
whether you want to file with the help
of an expert or let an expert file for
you
turbo tax live experts give you the
confidence to know that you're uniquely
you that your uniquely you taxes are
done right
intuit turbo tax live thank you turbotax
for sponsoring today's episode
thank you sign on fire taxes seriously
don't forget
first story you guys major controversy
kim kardashian hits back at major major
kim kardashian is hitting back at people
who are questioning her daughter north's
painting abilities
she says how dare you she was not she
did not come to play she did not come to
play it's funny like what sets her off
but this is clearly
one of those things doubting like it's
doubters
non-believers once
no anyone who doubts north's abilities
like that is obviously a trigger point
for kim kardashian west
we know that now we do and she is one
proud mom she's not afraid to stick up
for her children
the star recently shared a photo of a
landscape painting her daughter north
had completed
calling the seven-year-old a little
artist in an instagram story post
however social media users quickly began
questioning whether or not north had
actually painted the artwork
which was done in a style similar to the
works of bob ross
one twitter user one twitter user wrote
i'm supposed to go but i can't stop
thinking about how northwest did not
paint this
then kim took to her story and wrote a
lengthy post saying
don't play with me when it comes to my
children my daughter and her best friend
have been taking a serious oil painting
class
where their talents and creativity are
being encouraged and nurtured
north worked incredibly hard on her
painting with which took several weeks
to complete as a proud mom i wanted to
share her work with everyone
so she's like coming after specific
articles specific tweets
saying how dare you come for north how
dare you question her child's abilities
and that north
is the artistic queen that she said that
she was and then on tick-tock
these two girls from calabasas who like
i think when they were kids took that
same art class
they had their paintings from when they
were kids and they're like no this
actually is what like art class is like
in calabasas
so i'm not gonna lie like when i first
saw it i'm like lol kim like north did
not paint that
did i feel like vocalizing it on the
internet and being a troll no i just
thought to myself like
okay there's like there's some i don't
know where we lied but there's a
fabrication in this like someone helped
like there's a little bit of a lie
i don't think so i think but then then
it came to be isn't it a paint by the
numbers i like when i first saw it i
assumed it was paint by number so when i
figured that i'm like oh no
they can make anyone a good painter yeah
and she spent weeks in her oil painting
class like i just
people are constantly underestimating
and they're constantly
embarrassing themselves with that
congratulations you played yourself
obviously like i had no doubts that
north made this because also like why
would she say that she made it if she
didn't make it mostly it's just my faith
in kim that made me believe
right right no and it's like when you
have that big of a platform like you
really just can't lie about
random [ __ ] right or you shouldn't we
don't know kim to lie
especially about north but it also is
interesting that in her supportive
claims about um in her instagram stories
she was had a picture of some art and
referred and cut she in the context of
the story she was referring to kanye and
instead of calling kanye she called him
north stad
she said throwback to some of her dad's
artwork that he did when he was a kid
which some people are taking to me like
she can't even utter his name they're
divorced which i took to mean like
this is a story about north and it's
north's dad showing her
artistic ability i really appreciate
like the level of denial you are
reaching but no like
this is how you refer to the father of
your children who you're no longer
married to like the children's father
i saw a story like on her stories before
it was a news story and i was like oh
that's so cute like i didn't think
anything of it i think people
are just looking too into it no um
i feel as though i've been on the denial
train with you for quite some time
but i did think that was intentional
weird wording
i don't think so i think it's just all
about north like and i think that if kim
like
didn't want to mention connie she
wouldn't have posted it at all like
she's posting his young artwork so sweet
i think this whole story is so sweet i
love north's painting like
can't wait till it's art vandalize
original they should you know what i
love
you're just so sweet
like you just really believe like in the
good you know i believe in in my people
you know for sure and i was really there
with you but i think at this point like
i'm not saying that they're not getting
divorced i'm just saying i have no
reason to believe right now that they
are because kim hasn't said anything to
me
okay anyways welcome to you are you
waiting for a text message i'm waiting
for
the statement from kim's ig just like
she spoke on north
yeah you know there's all these rumors
flying she did not hesitate to correct
this one no don't come for her [ __ ]
children don't come for her children
looking forward to the northwest art
vandelay collab
whenever it drops you know i think often
about those pieces that chloe made
during her
stint as our best family no they were
really really good and
once they got them framed side by side
like the red and the black
i was like i would fully put that in my
home where are they they should auction
them for charity because i would [ __ ]
buy that 100 but it also goes to show
how a nice frame can make
anything look fabulous no that's why you
need frame rate
to not today sponsor but you're right
like the proper just like a nice canvas
like some decent paint and a
fancy art frame and you're right like
it's just
it's enough yeah that was so true those
were some really funny episodes but
where do we think that they live i think
they're probably in chris jenner's home
no i don't i think they're in chloe's
garage did you ever watch the um
home edit episode of chloe's garage no
they weren't in there
they literally went through all of her
stuff like true has uh 117 of those like
mini cars that every kid wanted when
they were a kid that like really drove
she was like a bentley a range rover
like she's the craziest [ __ ]
um all of chloe's paint supplies are in
there that she made it into like her
paint studio
but there were no framed pieces hanging
around maybe she has like a little
you know room in her house where they're
all hanging or maybe they're in the
attic
and then she also had like a huge corner
for like all the merch she gets
from herself like her collabs with like
an american and all these other
and then her sister's collabs that like
they sent her oh that's so nice that's
what i need
yeah i need a merch room like the merch
that we have that's why i have to wear
it today just because like there was
literally no room for it in my closet no
i'm out of room for it like i always
have like a couple piles of marshmallows
now we have numerous shopping on
february 17th and you guys it is
sickening the warehouse down the
warehouse is still sick
no the warehouse who am i the warehouse
yes because they're [ __ ] sick from
the most sickening merchandise just
sitting on their shelves you guys will
get some sneak peeks coming soon but the
drop is on wednesday february 17th gird
your loins
skirt your [ __ ] lion
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyways justice for north has been
served once again
stop doubting her yes that's the the
true lesson here it's like
kim is her mother kanye west is her
father she is the firstborn in judaism
we call that the bachor it's for a boy
but still it counts
we must as a society stop doubting
northwest's abilities like
homegirl like she will be the first you
know
something you know she's going to be
like whenever she's an astronaut yeah
like
she's going to kill it yeah so if she
wants to be the next bob ross
she'll be it she will be okay next up is
a crazy story that has been like
circulating on the web but
cops are now denying this wild rumor
that army hammer is a suspect in a death
investigation
like literally it's crazy that like
instagram pages like dumoan like a bunch
of these other gossip sites like
they literally started the swimmer
police have shut down a wild
online rumor that armie hammer is a
suspect in california's wonder valley
death investigation
after hikers discovered human remains in
the california desert on january 31st
social media ran rampant with
speculation linking the 34 year old
actor
who's caught up in his own scandal to
the case the rumors began
after instagram account du moy yeah
shared posts claiming that a shocking
story about hammer via me
dropped him got it so if you saw the
post on du moy and then there was like
i always say different every time it's
friends i say different every time but
there was also these tweets going around
saying that like army hammer at one
point in this year was like working in
construction
and which is just a very bizarre thing
for an actor to do right
and then also like at that same time
some bodies were found
very close by and he was working on a
movie that was set
near this location where the bodies were
found so it was like there wasn't
there wasn't not evidence like
when i read it i'm like this could be
true and also with dumois
saying that um a big article was about
to come out about army that was so
damning that
that his agency was coming preemptively
dropped him it was right
and we're still waiting like according
to now a lot of people like the la times
is working on like a major piece
on army hammer that has something so
damning in it like it's worse than
anything we've ever seen so it's like
we've seen something really bad the
logical next thing like what's worse
than cannibalism
murder like so it's not a crazy thought
so when all these things were happening
at the same time we heard about the
article something jamming was coming
someone put together like with this
dead body like it didn't not make sense
yeah it wasn't
like crazy so crazy um but now the san
bernardino county sheriff told the sun
that army hammer's name hasn't come up
as a suspect at all we have no plans to
investigate him
he's probably relieved about that so i
guess that's that on that yeah but that
was a crazy few days
sometimes rumors were like so crazy that
we actually didn't even talk about them
because that's like but you know now the
police are getting involved it's insane
if wrong
it's speculation and like conspiracy
theory at its finest 100
but now the police spoke on it we as a
legitimate news source here like we can
speak on it
right so and by speaking on it we're
saying that these two things and i feel
like a lot of people like saw those
tweets and were like
question mark waiting for the story
right so i guess here we are to tell you
that that's not going to be the story
but still
pending this mysterious l.a times story
that's so bad
that trump's cannibalism right i'm very
much looking forward to reading
that piece if it ever sees the light of
day yes i have a feeling like because we
know about it it probably never existed
yeah like someone somewhere is working
to get it stopped no it's like a game of
telephone like like this the article
never existed you know
yeah like i think it's very logical that
his agency would drop him
not because if something's coming
because of all that's already happened
like
but an agency's job is to make you money
and at some point i've been dropped by
an agency at some point
due to a scandal like you are no longer
lucrative for
an agency yes but all of this cannibal
stuff came out a few weeks ago
it did take them a very long time it
took my agency um like one hour to drop
me and i didn't hurt anybody so
he's hypocrisy yeah
hypocrisy yeah he's been america's next
top council for a while
that's funny thank you and you know i
always i've been thinking a lot like i
just wonder
like first of all like where is he like
where is he experiencing the
cancellation
from is it a house is it a hotel has he
seen his kids
what is going through his mind does he
feel like he's being framed like is he
sorry like i'm just questioning
his statement he thinks he's being
framed right but that statement was so
long ago like i don't even i don't even
remember like i don't know her like i
don't know that statement it was like
it was written in all caps and it was
supposed to be like written by a
publicist it looks like it was written
by a child it looked like
northwest wrote it well then it would be
amazing if she wrote it
so stay tuned next story
a little happy royal beb news hrbn
hrbn it's time for a little h r
b n ready okay princess eugenie shares
the adorable first photo of her newborn
son
on instagram princess eugenie's
welcoming her first child in a modern
way with an instagram post
that is true this is like a first royal
with an instagram photo that reminds me
very much of kylie and stormies
and very much of olivia and michaela i
know this like
hand-holding baby announcement is is all
the rage right now and it's
so sweet no because it's like the mom is
[ __ ] tired she just like
gave birth created a child and people
like i have seen people like getting
their hair and makeup done
in the hospital which you know good for
you i'm not here to judge anyone but
like that will not be me like i will
literally i probably won't even have a
manicure i can tell you someone who it
will be
you i will there's literally two types
of girls in the world
girls who do the hand holding thing and
girls who get their hair and makeup done
well no i'm not gonna get my hair and
makeup done but i am definitely gonna be
putting some foundation on you know how
red i get like i would be
crazy no a foundation and a brow and a
lash i'm not gonna have a makeup artist
i don't even have a makeup artist like
for my wife right that's true
yeah um i'm gonna bring up an example
that i've recently found out that you
say i bring up all the time but um
what to expect when you're expecting
that scene where like brooklyn decker
sneezes out two twins and that there's
two types of i am elizabeth banks like
all the way and like you are brooklyn no
no no yes oh no oh no
no no no no i mean it remains to be seen
also you could say there's two types of
pregnant women courtney and kim
yeah that's so true and i'm much more of
a kim
for sure safe for sure but we shall see
you never know
anything can happen when you're
expecting yeah and you never know what
to expect
when you're expecting okay the first
photo princess eugenie and jack burke
spanx baby boy was shared on the royals
instagram page on tuesday the black and
white shot shows their baby's hand
wrapped around eugenie's thumb while
jack holds the baby boy's arm you know
that is a new touch of both parents
hands in the photo
yeah you know i feel like you know the
mom did more work like let her have her
moment but okay whatever
yeah but it's still really cute uh she
captioned the shot
with blue heart emojis and two
exclamation points to show her
excitement
i i really am like not over the fact
that it's like royal announcement news
on instagram i think that's so cool
no but it is it's so 21st century of
them the queen yet again ushering the
monarchy into a new era
um so i found this out because like uh
on people magazine's instagram there was
a picture of them
and then it was like in the caption it
was like welcome
princess you know whatever and they
happen to have chosen like a really
unflattering picture of both of them and
the comments
were so mean mostly because like the
picture the picture of both of them had
a lot of teeth
and they were british teeth
yeah that's it i think it looks so cute
like so happy people are so
people are so mean but like you know
like when you're when you're you're
internal monologue when you're looking
at a picture like for me i would never
say anything
but i was looking at the picture i'm
like oh that's you know a lot of teeth
and then the comments were just like so
mean
damn justice just when the royals get on
instagram they're
now you're gonna make fun of them which
is like a british trope but it's not
nice
i'm not even reading them no that ain't
right no i know but um that's how i
found out about the british new baby
okay well very happy warm wishes
yes to this new family i feel like
whenever we bring up eugenie like we
always say like ideal level of royal
fame like she probably
has a small semblance of a normal life i
think we say the opposite actually i'm
having deja vu we can literally have
this conversation because she has all
of the responsibility and none of the
perks
no i disagree she doesn't have the perks
yes she does
no she doesn't she has the money i don't
know
isn't that like the only perk and the
fame yeah no but like she's not like
but she doesn't have to go to as many
like state dinners as everyone else like
she probably i guess it it really just
depends what you think are
responsibilities right what you think
are perks yeah no
you know so right i think that most
people see a state dinner as a
responsibility
but to me sounds fabulous perk yeah but
not when you have them like every night
and you have to like wear these heavy
like
dresses and sashes and crowns and jewels
it depends on the person because to me
that sounds amazing to someone else
not every night for your whole life a
couple times a year rounds and jewels
and sashes
oh my okay are you ready for our next
story
i'm ready come and
find me i'm not gonna hang on the sun
outside
heavy comes
[Laughter]
no thank you open for the one and i'm
ready
ready they just can't be the right there
no we're definitely seeing them wrong
but we had a dance like made up to that
when we were kids
oh yeah we have a big kick yeah and it
was like red
[ __ ] [ __ ] did you hit the corner
no i'm actually gonna cry
oh no i'm okay did you hit the corner of
the mic
box with your tendon
[Laughter]
i think this next story is going to
cheer you up honestly it better be about
alex trebek
it is his jeopardy wardrobe is being
donated to a homeless organization
some of the wardrobe worn by the beloved
jeopardy host
has been donated to the doe fund a
nonprofit that provides housing
vocational training
continuing education and other services
for formerly homeless and incarcerated
new yorkers
the doctor joe fund is the best
organization it's such a fabulous
organization
do they come i know when we were in high
school they came and talked
to students yes and that's how i first
heard about it and now if you're ever on
the street
you'll see people who work for the doe
fund ready willie and abel and the blue
suits
um you see them everywhere and i'm so
glad they're still around because like i
first heard about them in high school
like maybe 10 years ago
yes and that's it's just like it's
they're an organization that like
they just have their [ __ ] together like
they've been around forever they've
proven success and they i'm sure they
are
so excited about this donation yes
during his last day on set alex extolled
the virtues of
everyone opening up their hands in their
hearts to those who are suffering
donating his wardrobe to those who are
working to rebuild their lives
is the perfect way to begin to honor
that last request said mike richards who
is the executive producer of jeopardy
among the donated items are 14 suits 58
dress shirts 300 ties
25 polo shirts 14 sweaters 9 sports
coats
nine pairs of dress shoes fifteen belts
two parkas and three pairs of dress
slacks
the clothes will go to participants in
the doe funds re-entry program called
ready willing and able
as a tire suitable for job interviews oh
my god that's so sweet and it's like
we all yet again can learn another
valuable lesson from alex trebek and
it's like
even after he's gone his legacy is just
lives on lives on this is so
so nice and i love he's from canada i
don't even know like
you know how he knows about the doe fund
does he not
oh i don't know and they film in l.a
yeah maybe the um
the executive producer mine is from the
call yeah yeah it might be it's so great
like when i saw this on like one of
those good news instagrams i was
crying like it's so sweet it's an
amazing story and they have pictures of
the recipients with their like and like
not only do you get like a fancy suit
like it was worn by a celebrity like
yeah historically i
think yeah we love to see it we do just
a really great story
and our fifth and final story is some
interesting news celebs jerry seinfeld
debbie mazar and more will be voicing
nyc subway psas
no thank god so the stand clear of the
closing doors announcement is getting a
star-studded makeover oh i love this
with a dose of gritty new york attitude
starting friday a collection of new york
city's notable natives including jerry
seinfeld debbie mazar and whoopi
goldberg
will be iconic iconic we'll be voicing
the mt
the mta subway and bus announcements as
part of a new initiative
to breathe life into the pandemic weary
public transport
system we need it debbie mazar says the
subway is part of my dna i'm so excited
to do this i want subway riders to feel
welcome
i want them to hear a familiar voice
think for a second and maybe smile
we you know what of course i like who
they have but they really should have
also included like howard stern and andy
cohen
okay sorry just maybe that would be like
the next installment but i think when
you think of
um famous iconic new yorkers obviously
jerry seinfeld yeah i don't think of
debbie mazar i did not even know she
lived here she has such a great and
distinct voice
yes and whoopi goldberg it's like like
if can you imagine like
after a long day like on the way home so
excited to get home and then you hear
like the warm delicious voice of whoopi
goldberg
that's a great one yeah that's a really
really good one oh
i think that there are more um but the
campaign was spearheaded by director
nicholas heller who's behind the
instagram account at new york nico where
he features like big applicable
characters the mtv i reached out to him
for ideas for how to spice up the subway
look at the mta being forward thinking
like can't get their trains running on
time but reach out to an influencer
there's such a disconnect here but okay
yeah
he approached about 50 prominent new
yorkers from across different
industries and no one like had an issue
to participate even though there's no
money involved he landed 25 of them
including
fran leibowitz probably another great
new york voice
rappers jada kiss and cameron comedians
de zeus and mero radio
jesus jesus sorry radio personalities
angela yee and angie martinez
and sportscaster michael k so there's
there's a lot of different voices i
think this is going to be a really
cool and hopefully ongoing campaign
where your voices could always be added
well you know i would love to hear from
jerry seinfeld you know after he made
like a huge you know ta-da over the
summer
you know yeah new york's coming back i
guess this is his way of helping i think
this is his way of helping this is you
know a lot of people's ways of
doing something exciting for the city
yeah so i think that it's a it's a cool
interesting little factoid no i like it
a lot but
i think it's like a little bit again
like celebrities thinking that they're
gonna just like save the world oh
well yeah it's a little bit of that but
it's more so like if you live in new
york like you know how
we are riddled with problems and like
the voice of the mta man like wasn't at
the top of our list it's more like
you know the crime and there's just like
all so many restaurants closing like the
economy
so i feel like maybe call me crazy we
should tackle some of those first
and then worry about who's going to tell
us what the next stop is right
exactly and i'm going to miss that guy
and i know he was stand clear of the
closing doors
please and like whenever i hear that it
just like triggers me actually back to
nyu like i just say
so maybe like getting some new voices in
there we can create new memories
i'm actually really okay with that yeah
and if they need some like young new
york voices
to say good morning mta
welcome to times square the home of
broadway
we are available we are yeah we could do
some more like um
okay okay okay no say if you don't get
off at your next stop you'll be remiss
you'll be devastated you'll be
heartbroken and even
heartbroken and then it's like i'll do
all the ones for like the theater
district so like
next stop lincoln center home of the
hopper
and then we'll be like hear the sounds
the marching fee
on the avenue i'm taking you to 42nd
street if they're not playing that every
time they hit 42nd street what is you
doing
and then and then when they there's i
don't think there is a 57th street stop
but if they're
no actually it's 59th yeah there's also
57th and 7th
lines i i would be like i was walking
towards 57th street towards park
with my same old song in my same old
heart
thinking when i'm gonna do when i get
older
claudia that's [ __ ] beautiful yeah i
could come up with a whole slate of
songs like mention
if you're on the six and you're heading
north up town
and if you're on the six just like
between stops
i was running through the six with my
woes
you know how that should go just a
little something like that yeah oh
and then if i was on the four train a
little chat jackson
only got four minutes to save the world
hesitated
oh and then when it's the final final
stop you know when they get all the way
north or all the way south
and everyone has to get off i want to
see
you out that door baby
that's beautiful or if they're on the r
train are you ready for it
oh that's good and the doors will the
door and we'll have a fog machine
machine lights lights and fog
every day on your way to work this could
literally be like
the best project like i really could
come up with like a pop culture
music themed extravaganza a hundred
percent
a hundred percent i could i could go on
no i could
wax poetic yeah oh and then you know
like
oh the empire state building um stop new
york
concrete jungle wet dream tomato
there's nothing you can't do
okay i really don't want to stop but i
think no like i could go
on forever oh and then when the train
comes to a stop
you know sometimes like between between
stops like you get stuck in the tunnel
because like the lights don't work or
something yes
um when it comes to a screeching halt
stop
in the name of love
before you break my heart
just an idea so once again we are
available or if you want to hire
real singers you can do that too the
ideas are free mta i
i'm a real singer so just for sure but
i'm gonna say the ideas are free
no really intellectual property no but
i'm
giving them to the mta for those are you
ready for closing doors like so funny
i will supply the [ __ ] you can't put a
friend again
okay now moving on to your toasters
which is our advice segment what we do
every wednesday we take advice and if
you want to ever
no we give advice and if you ever have a
query
query quandary query quandary pickle
that you're in
email us deartoasters gmail.com and we
will do our best to read your advice on
air completely anonymously
and the deer toaster segment is brought
to you by sweaty betty
new year new chance to kick butt 2021 is
the perfect time to take your fitness to
the next level with a pair
of london's most popular sweaty betty
power leggings
make any move you want knowing your
leggings have got your backside being
more active is one of the most common
new year's eve resolutions but a third
of workouts get skipped
one of the main reasons why is because
of bad workout clothing so excuse proof
your workouts with sweaty betty's power
leggings i
love leggings i'm a firm believer that
leggings are pants and anyone who tells
you any differently is just
super toxic so i'm always looking for
the best
legging i really am and sweaty betty i
knew i've i've heard of forever
and i just got a pair like two weeks ago
and they're fabulous like they're firm
they're tight they don't
i hate the drop crotch like that is no
they're so good i actually wore my
sweaty betty leggings
yesterday to work workout at home and
now that i'm
thinking about it like first of all they
felt amazing but i wound up doing more
i did three workouts because i just
didn't want to get off right
and i i think there's a direct
correlation and they have pockets which
is because you you know you need a
little granola bar stick it in the
pocket you need your airpods
case 100 but like i loved the way the
leggings felt yesterday and i didn't
want to get off the bike and i think
there's a correlation just saying no
other athletic brand can compete with
the sweaty betty power leggings
expertly placed seams and squat tested
compression fabric that sculpt your bum
into its instant peach emoji status so
they're quick drying and they have the
pockets in the back and the side
their power leggings are high-waisted
squat proof performers with expertly
placed seams
that make you look and feel at the top
of your game anytime you want to sweat
their opaque fabric adjustable
drawstring waist and pockets make your
workout look as good as it feels
because you deserve to look amazing
before during and after your workout
go to sweatybetty.com toast and use our
code
toast at checkout to get 20 off your
purchase this is the best offer sweaty
betty has available anywhere
and it's spelled s-w-e-a-t-y-b-e-t-t-y
dot com slash toast and then you have to
use our code at check out
sweatybetty.com toast promo code
toast love it okay um okay dear toasters
ready
hi claudia and jackie hi hi
claude congrats on being a new york
times bestseller your book was
everything of the sort thank you
my boyfriend is a p john and we moved in
together seven months ago in his
hometown
where all of his close friends and
families still live this is a huge deal
for me because i moved far away from my
sisters friends and parents to be with
him
i have a couple friends in the area but
due to cove that i haven't been able to
make any more
i still struggle living away from my
friends and family but i love living
with him
there is one issue i need my two
disgraced queens to help me with
my boyfriend has a friend let's call her
gaby
they've been friends since middle school
and have a weirdly close relationship
she is single and they are constantly
texting and she is always at my
apartment
i've gone snooping before and haven't
found anything incriminating but it
still weirds me out
her family owns a restaurant and every
time we go out to eat we go there so we
can see gabby
they are both part of this larger
friends group that is friend group that
is always hanging out while i'm left at
home watching reruns of real housewives
of new jersey
and i just eat my weight and salt and
vinegar chips i've been wondering why am
i not invited to these hangouts his
other friends bring their significant
others and he never invites me
the one time i did hang out with his
friends it was really fun but i've never
been invited back
i'm starting to think that he is not
inviting me because gabby is there and
he doesn't want us in the same room
am i being crazy or do you think that
something weird is going on with gabby
and my boyfriend
i truly love my boyfriend so much and i
see myself marrying him but my mind is
going to the worst places
sincerely a sad toaster there's a lot to
unpack here the first is obviously like
should or can your fiance who's a male
have
a friend that's a girl we can talk about
that but i think the second thing like
your boyfriend like constantly hanging
out with his group of friends girls and
boys and not inviting he was really
[ __ ] up seeing as how like
you gave up so much to move away all
your friends and family are back at home
you have very few friends in this town
especially because of coved and he has
like a full-blown group of friends
infrastructure and you can come that's
right like first of all because
you moved your whole life for him and
like gave him everything that he wanted
like you pretty much should get
everything that you want like from now
until eternity so if you want to be
hanging out with
friends like just say i moved here for
you like i'm going you know you have so
you need to like wield that a little
more yeah um and it's a little bit
shady that he wouldn't include you to
begin with like maybe he thinks you
don't want to be there because honestly
watching real housewives of new jersey
and eating salted mining chips
sounds like a really good time but no
like just stand up for yourself and
that's not right and as far as gabby
goes like once you're in these
situations you can
get a pulse on her and if you think that
it's it's not good
tell him i moved here for you you're not
allowed to be friends with gaby anymore
yeah
it sounds like you're forgetting like
you're in charge gabby doesn't run this
town
you do 100 but then the conversation
about
him having like a close friend like abby
so of course like i'm such a jealous
person like
when i think about it i'm like okay no
and if that were ben like i would kill
someone but honestly like abe like is
one of my best friends i hang out with
him all the time i facetime him like
four hours at a time and
like ben doesn't feel weird about it and
like there's literally nothing to feel
weird about so sometimes it
is just a friend but i do think it's not
to be like so you know
1950s like i think it's fine for a girl
to have a guy friend but i don't think
it's fine for a guy to have a girlfriend
i think there's just
um context is everything per usual like
one what's her situation like is she in
a relationship two yeah
and you know what makes it weird the
fact that gabby has like no relationship
with the fiance
like abe and ben have hung out multiple
times before like
he's like a couple of friends if you
have to keep it separate you're doing
something wrong
if everyone's together as friends it's a
beautiful thing but i think like
let's hear more about gabby before we
judge her yeah
you don't really know her yeah no but
you obviously just hate her even for us
too like is she in a relationship like
what is her deal right like does she
have a history of like you know
being a skank like what like no is she
history being a man stealer like what's
the
yeah i mean skank that's like a
derogatory word i apologize but like has
she you know hooked up with other
people's fiances or live-in boyfriends
you know
live in boyfriends next up it's like so
nice you moved like into this small town
for your boyfriend honestly sounds epic
i wish ben was no 100 percent maybe we
should move there and then we could like
yeah gabby yeah we're not going to your
restaurant we're going to the competing
restaurant
that's so mean okay
hi claudia and jackie i must start off
by saying i listen to the podcast daily
and i love you guys
i need some advice and i'd be rdh if i
didn't come here i am seriously rdh i'm
a dental hygienist oh my god she's a
registered dental she better have got
that sweatshirt
i had a patient a few weeks ago and i
saw him both and
i had a patient a few weeks ago i saw
both him and his son
my patient is about 55 and his son is
14. the dad was a little creepy and
complimented my hands more than once but
whatever
i was talking to the both of them about
skiing and how i recently picked it up
over the
quarantine i was walking the dad out to
leave and he offered me a pair of skis
that are too big for his son
i took it with a grain of salt and kind
of i was
i was working brought in his son to have
some work done and he brought me the
skis
i was so awkward and uncomfortable he
just left them in my office i took them
home but i feel a little unprofessional
and totally weird if this is this guy's
way of flirting with me what do i do do
i call them and say they don't fit i
can't accept them or do i just keep them
i mean it's free skis and they fit is
this wrong of me they please help
that's really rdh toaster i mean girl
keep the skis like life is expensive if
you you get a free pair of skis don't
question it
yeah and honestly like sending them back
like also makes it awkward it doesn't
coordinate like the pickup it's awkward
regardless because he seems like just an
awkward guy i mean obviously monitor the
situation if anything feels like truly
creepy reported
but but right now it seems like he's
maybe just like a nice guy like with a
free pair of
like really generous like that yes i
have this thing that i don't need and
you need it like
here you go that just makes complete
sense no and like i'm you could say like
i'm generous but you have to come to my
house and pick it up i'm not driving out
of my way to drop it off for you like
yeah it's your gift yeah but i guess he
really just some people are do-gooders i
don't know i was doing the wicked ride
on peloton yesterday and that song came
on no good deed goes unpunished and i'm
like
so true that's how this man will feel if
you return the skis so yeah you don't
want to make him feel better let him do
the good deed until he gives you a
reason to think that there was like
another
reason behind it i just want to see the
good in people
and it sounds like you don't like feel
uncomfortable by by his presence it's
just like it's really not a normal thing
to do
yeah it's just like super [ __ ] extra
but i mean he likes you like you have a
pair of skis when where are we going
yeah where are we going i'll meet you in
aspen shred the [ __ ] gnar y'all
okay ready dear jack claude and theodora
love you guys so much thank you for
everything you do in bringing a smile to
a millennial's face oh my god you're so
welcome
i have physical proof that my boss's
husband
is sleeping with our co-worker and is
now
borderline stalking her okay so the
bosses oh my goodness
the cake boss's husband so the boss
i guess okay the boss's husband is
sleeping with a co-worker
and that was stalking her and now he's
talking to her we all work in the same
office
my boss is ally the co-worker is chelsea
and the husband is james
hold on boss is ally co-workers chelsea
husband is james got it i like i'm like
reading this but i can't comprehend it
do you ever have
that happen yes i'm like these are just
letters like okay
boss is ally so the co-worker and the
husband
chelsea and james wow very good i'm like
i'm not able to digest this
no i can read it james and chelsea used
to be super
super flirty and it was really
uncomfortable i would look over at ali
and
it seemed like she was ignoring it james
and chelsea would disappear for over an
hour at a time
and when chelsea would come back she
would have an elaborate story about
traffic spilling coffee on herself and
so on
fast forward a couple months and she
admits to someone that she was sleeping
with him in his car
he would also give her money for
manicures highlights and whatever she
wanted
now she says she's over him but still
accepts money and gifts and get this
he sends her gifts to the office and
chelsea leaves them on her desk for ally
to see
would you somehow want ali to know there
is a rumor that james that this isn't
the first time james has been screwing
around ali is a precious gem of a woman
and does not deserve any of this
signed monkey in the middle of a scandal
it sounds like you've got to stop
butting in people's business like i know
but it also sounds like you should write
her a letter
anonymous dear sam the other night the
other night
at james's car hr chelsea
james put his head between chelsea's
breasts yeah yeah i mean
my inclination is always just like butt
the [ __ ] out of people's business
especially at work like
work yes isn't your life you know you go
to work to live you got to make your
money like it's not
everything so just like i don't know
keep your head that's my advice seems
like you're like really invested in it
emotionally and like
i just i'm not that type of person i'm
like my co-worker's like you can all go
[ __ ] yourselves like i'm getting out of
it it's literally
just me no and that hurts i mean like if
i was in a typical setting with people i
wasn't related to
okay like i'm just not the type of
person like in a corporate setting like
to care that much yeah yeah i own my own
company so like now like yes i'm very
passionate about everyone
here but like if i was just like a cog
in a machine yeah
i would do my cog work make my money so
i can go get drinks like yeah
keep your head down that's my advice
yeah i would try to i think it's really
hard
um and i i
again no good d goes unpunished so if
you tell ally like you then you're a
part of this like
everyone shoots the messenger and then
you're the office snitch ugh
i hate to see and that's a label that's
very very hard to get rid of
yeah i would um try and stay out of it
yeah um also sorry that's like boring
advice
yeah but i think you prudent there also
can be more that you don't know like so
just
leave it alone yeah maybe they're a
throbble like yeah don't involve
yourself like you know what
everything everything works itself out
in the end it really does
yeah the cream always rises and that's
our show that is our show nobody else's
our show nobody else's show none
whatsoever no we have to
read real housewives of dallas oh yeah
that's a britney documentary that's
actually not our show
okay so real housewives of dallas super
quick um
was such a boring episode and it was
kind of like the worst edit for tiffany
moon of all time
yes i think it was a boring episode but
it was very illustrative of people's
personalities yeah and
i think that tiffany moon has had like a
really great season so far and now it's
like
everything about everything that she did
in last night's episode and hosting
people in her house like
was totally crazy she is a control freak
and she's not a good host like no and
she's also a control freak which is by
the way like sometimes can be endearing
and like you cut like you know
if you're self-aware about it and it's
funny but she was just like going about
everything in the wrong way and it
really
reached a pinnacle when she was the
reason why brandi
needed to throw up and then also made
brandy put on booties in order to go
into the house
to throw up like yeah that was crazy
right because it's not
being a control freak isn't a bad thing
but it's the way that she controls
that's so
derogatory i think like and that's what
cameron was saying like when she
corrected her grammar like it's okay to
correct someone's
grammar but like it def she has this way
of like treating talking to other people
like their kids like
you will put your booties on you will go
to the bathroom you will take your
booties off
you will come outside like it was just
very condescending yeah so i think
that's what rubbed people the wrong way
more so even the way she sent the text
message okay you need to have people out
of your house by 11.
you as the host you can make that happen
you don't have to send a text message
like to make people
feel unwelcome in your home at 10 31
yeah it was
all kind of done in the wrong way and
also it takes the fun out of everything
like
nobody wants to feel like you're an
imposition in someone else's house it's
like why am i here
if i can't even walk into the house
without shoes or i can't go to the
bathroom like
why did i come here and honestly she
should have just had everyone take their
shoes off and like give away give out
flip-flops or something
yeah because i i i respect and i know
that it's a really big thing in asian
culture and it makes a lot of sense
subway shoes it makes complete sense and
to have them wear the booties like
through the house when they go to the
outside sure i just thought that in the
moment where brandi was throwing up like
it was extreme agreed like at some point
the booties we can forget about
especially because tiffany felt so
terribly that she was the reason why
brandi needed to throw up yeah and the
prank thing
um i think it's i like the idea of
pranking especially because it's huge in
this group of girls especially with
brandy obviously
but it is um it's a difficult thing when
you're pranking somebody with something
like say you were allergic say you're
allergic say you're kosher like
like if someone put crickets in my food
like that's not okay that's not okay
yeah and so i thought like a lot of the
people had had different reactions like
i thought deandra like
handled it like the best i think mostly
she feels protective over tiffany
because
she brought her into the group so she
was like oh it's not a big deal and then
carrie brady also d'andra we know
is the most advanced eater yes carrie
brittingham like was just so annoying
she's like i knew it i knew it like
no you didn't first of all you literally
had no idea she got you 100
and then she was just like she was fine
with it like she was just being she was
just mad because she doesn't like
tiffany like
she's just making things up and like
trying to make her feel bad brandy on
the other hand like
like that was really unfortunate you
know and like that's why you don't do a
prank like that
right so it just felt bad for her
because like she like tried to get him
with like the pranksters and like
that's not a good place to start no
there's nothing sadder than like a prank
on a ride like that and she
ended it like feeling so bad like randy
felt so bad it was just
not well it was not good yeah i'm like
so excited
for uh cameron wescott's new home like i
just need her old house to sell and i
need to see the inside of the house
i know i love cameron's home scene so
much like first of all
bruno loves watching fancy like he
always
pays down the treadmill yeah what's
fancy doing right like accountability
coach
fancy's in the car like loves fancy and
i
i feel like i actually learn a lot about
dog training like from her scenes with
the dog trainer so it's like typically i
would probably be uninterested in like
someone's dog like that's your story
line but she makes it so funny
and interesting and i just like love her
family
me too and another person who's um like
family scenes or
personal scenes i really like is
stephanie holman and the holman
foundation like just
um learning the intricacies of like
standard lockers cost
275 000 like that's crazy and i actually
think it's such a nice
i'm like when they were like we're gonna
give away lockers i'm like who needs a
locker
in their house but like she's doing it
um for schools and and colleges that are
um
struggling and it's actually such a nice
way to get concept
yeah and i can't wait to see what the
holmen foundation accomplishes
yeah no it's it's really cute and it's
cute watching her and travis work
together and i love that they do
confessionals together because they're
always
so funny your back is hairy peach fuzz
he's like you're fuzzy i'm hairy
no they're really really cute i agree
but it was a crazy um
dinner party or it was just did not look
fun no it did not look so many
rules and it's such a fun concept and
tiffany's house is so amazing oh it's so
nice and i feel like it could have been
such a fun night and it was just one of
those like disaster evenings
and i found it weird because i think the
whole point of the party and tiffany had
said
was she really wants to get to know the
girls and she wants
them to get to know her and she was just
like forcing it so much
that like every time she shared an
anecdote it felt so awkward like when
she said like
i used to pronounce jalapenos jalapenos
like that is a funny thing but like
she was just like forcing the
conversation on everyone and like
everyone was like like no one was
talking about that before
so the whole thing i felt like she was
just really uncomfortable the whole time
because she cares and also like when you
are a control freak like having people
in your house like i feel like i can be
that way too where it's like i'm more
stressed
hosting people than i am like even i
feel like when they went and had dim sum
like she was so much more
relaxed and in your home it's very
personal yeah and you have a lot there's
like so many things
happening and so i think she was really
overwhelmed and
her intention for the night turned out
to be the complete opposite
yeah well we'll see what happens next
week at least it was interesting and
that pizza oven just looks so good
yeah oh and if you're living for real
housewives of dallas we have a very
special
moment on the toast tomorrow i don't
want to spoil anything but just make
sure you check back in with us tomorrow
yes if you're living for real houses of
dallas think i'm really
i'm we're about to do we're we're
recording this segment right after this
we're about to do some
investigative [ __ ] journalism diane
sawyer like yeah we're nancy grace
we're about to get some answers for you
guys just call me nancy grace
nancy disgrace queen nancy disgraced
um now i want to talk about the britney
spears documentary which is a part of a
new york times series they're doing on
fx and one of the episode
is about brittany and oh there's only
one what's the series
it's like a it's like a documentary it's
different things each episode what are
some of the other episodes i didn't look
oh okay that's so interesting i didn't
know that that's what it was i haven't
watched yet the most recent one is
framing britney spears
and i don't know so it's just one short
it's an hour and ten minutes oh okay
i thought digestible like eights part no
i hate that [ __ ]
okay maybe i'll watch it tonight because
i know people really wanted to talk
about it but you're about to talk about
it
to be honest i don't really feel like i
learned anything new because you know we
did a deep dive on d
on free brittany um a few months ago so
like i'm pretty well versed
i grew up listening to brittany like i
remembered a lot of what they were
talking about
the conservatorship stuff is really
really interesting and i actually really
liked how the documentary like
found the people who are like there's a
podcast called like britney's world or
something like these two girls who are
obsessed with brittany dissecting it
they came up with the free brittany
movement um these podcasters were on the
new york times
um documentary which i thought was
really cool and they had legal experts
and stuff
obviously for me while i didn't learn
anything new from the documentary
the biggest takeaway was just like one
like how
even though the media is the worst like
we've made a lot of progress since like
britney's time like
just some of the clips they were showing
her being interviewed by diane sawyer
her being interviewed by
matt lauer um jokes that were being made
about her and late night
david letterman who like every time i
hear something like about david
letterman recently it makes me hate him
even more
um jay leno just the way we spoke about
like a 17 year old girl i'm like it was
just so
abhorrently disgusting and something
like that would never happen again but
really the documentary opened my eyes to
like how many people owe
britney spears an apology and like i
would really like to start first
with well matt lauer it was a lot of
people but like him
honestly and i hate to even point out
like the woman but like diane sawyer was
so grossly disappointing like the clips
they were showing it's just chilling you
can't you can't really believe that like
someone said this to brittany like
she's a 17 year old girl crying on this
interview and diane sawyer is like what
did you do to justin timberlake it's
like make him so upset
oh i heard justin timberlake comes out
looking he's on the list of people who
owe britney apology he like when they
broke up like he used it to his
advantage like
literally villainized her so much
insinuated in so many overt ways like
she cheated on him broke his heart they
were like america's sweetheart
america was very susceptible back in the
day to like listening to whatever the
tabloid said yes so the tabloid
narrative was like american royalty like
we don't have royals but like britney
and justin together like
that is american royalty and she
it was never really said like why they
broke up but justin made a music video
cry me a river like
all about brittany cheating on him and
like that was kind of the accepted
narrative and justin and his camp
really drove that home and i just want
to say
and that was the start of britney's like
it really was the start of her decline
wow mental health wise career-wise and
the conservatorship is
stuff is so is so crazy okay i will
watch it now that i know that it's not
like this whole long thing just want to
say i never liked that song crying a
river
yeah no and we have been really
preaching on here like so viciously
about how
justin timberlake is disgraceful like
now there's new york times said it so
like
it's true no i saw people were like
tagging me and stuff about how like this
is like that we were saying this first
and it's it's nice to um
we get a lot of flack for like not being
fans of his no i literally despise him
and after the documentary like i hate
him even more like he knew exactly what
he was doing oh my god
i'm going to hate him so much i know and
the documentary did just make me sad
because like they have all this behind
the scenes footage and like she really
was and they had like you know people
who worked for her as assistants
and agents she really was like what you
thought she was like southern belle
like surrounded herself with her family
so funny talented nice to everyone
even at the height of her fame and until
it took a turn where like her mental
health
was and like in all the interviews where
like people were talking about her like
they never even said mental health like
it was so clear she was struggling with
with some sort of like you know mental
health issue mental illness and like
no one would even acknowledge it you
know they just threw her in a
conservatorship
yeah and the league the legality now
they catch up to like 2019 and 2020. the
legality of the conservatorship is so
shady and they had this woman
who at the beginning of like the trials
with the conservatorship was on
jamie spears the dad's legal team and in
the middle of the documentary
i guess she got rehired for jamie spears
the dad and like
they literally had to put up a blurb
like she stopped filming because she
rejoined the legal team
wow yeah so what would be best for
brittany now so when people say free
britney what do they want for her
so britney's legal team isn't opposing
the conservatorship
they don't want her dad in charge of her
money anymore like they don't want him
involved at all brittany and it's
and in the whole documentary like
leading up to her you know becoming
famous
world tour he was never around like her
mom really took her out to all these
auditions and then when she became
famous she kept her mom and her
childhood friends around and her sister
but like the dad was not in the picture
like
he struggled with his business he filed
for bankruptcy i believe he went to
rehab
and so like he was never really in
brittany's life so now when she's at her
lowest and needs a conservator like why
would it be the dad
yeah so why is it him i don't know and
like
they recently got him to not be the
conservator of like her business but he
is still the conservative for finances
and he takes he gets paid as being the
conservative 1.5
of all of britney's earnings and for a
while he was in charge of
all of her business so he would
literally just make her work work work
work work
and there were those years like when she
was doing the vegas um and she had uh
circus and all those fragrances that was
when she was on the conservatorship and
she was like quote-unquote like behaving
and like
they would just literally put her out on
tour this
project campaign commercial making so
much money because
jamie was making money from it like
britney couldn't say yes or no like he
was legally allowed to make all of her
decisions for her
so now britney's case is i'm sure
brittany doesn't want to be in the
conservatorship but to get it expelled
is like legally
one of the lawyers was like i've never
seen it so her best chance is just to
get her dad
removed from it and hopefully like her
mom or she asks for a bank like a
financial institution
to be like the executive whatever of her
um conservatorship wow
and sam her boyfriend is just like you
know has found his voice and now that
people are talking about it i'm sure
he's like
known about this for a while he's like
posting on instagram talking to tmz like
jamie spears is a dick and what i did
learn is that the mom's name is lynn
and the dad's name is jamie and then we
have jamie lynn spears mm-hmm
so that was interesting that is jamie
lynn's fierce she wasn't in it
whatsoever
but what i also found interesting was
they have a brother like who knew
and he went on a podcast once and like
kind of spilled major tea
and like i never heard of the podcast
before and i would probably have never
known that he did a podcast but
he he was not holding back okay i'm
gonna watch it today guys it's actually
a really busy day so maybe this weekend
um
but yes i liked it very much even though
i didn't learn anything new it did just
make me angry which i think is what a
documentary is supposed to do
yeah or make you feel something yeah um
so that
is actually now that is our show yes
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube
subscribing give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
everybody catch box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow
goodbye